somebody from the new school like Justin
bonimo who's who's leading in terms of
cash wins is there somebody like that
that stands out to you as a potential uh
goat status person yeah so there's two
different ones but one is very so
they're both just no limit right so I
like again when I think of Poker I think
of you know a variety of games but
there's so many of the young guys that
specialize Michael Adamo is one that
I've mentioned several times and I love
the way that he approached the game
another one that's highly respected
because of his online prowess and his
his people have like looked and how
close he is to Game Theory and they say
he's about as perfect as you get and
it's like a kid named Linus Linus uh
line is Linus love online Linus linger
so he just came second recently I
believe in uh in the Triton huge Triton
so he's primarily an online player yeah
he's an online cash player for the most
part but he plays him live and he's you
know he's again and I respect the peers
that I play with who say yeah he's he's
tough as Nails there's another kid too
um Russian kid named Timothy kuznetsov
and he plays all the games and he's well
respected
um you know in that regard and same with
a guy like uh Jungle Man Dan Cates who's
a unique personality I mean this guy
showed up won the poker players
championship back-to-back years in a
Randy Macho Man Savage costume and he
was doing Macho Man the entire times oh
yeah I'm gonna take all the chips like I
did last year yeah bust them all and he
was in character for the entirety of the
term this is great just unique but uh
yeah respect for a lot of those guys
um is it gonna take time to figure out
who
um you know stands the test of time
that's such a thing right so a lot of
these kids like there was a guy who beat
me uh heads up in the uh million dollar
one drop I got 8.7 he won 15 million
dollars kid named Dan Coleman he was
seen as like you know the next big thing
in poker right he made his money
just wasn't for him so he's moved on you
know to doing what he's doing skiing in
the Alps whatever he's you know we have
nobody seen and from like five six years
so that can happen right because there
is a lot of burnout you know I think
like I think it was actually uh Gotham
chess who mentioned something about how
difficult it is to like I think it's
true in poker when you get really really
good at something
to get
this much better takes takes so much
work and a lot of people don't
necessarily want to put in that kind of
work in order to do that that's just
even staying at the same level takes a
huge amount of work yeah like so if you
want to get better at chassis you're
already like really really good and
you're trying to get like one little bit
better you have to study like in a
ridiculous amount you know and again
that's once you've already had I think
the toughest thing for anybody once
you've tasted success and you've already
retrieved it staying hungry staying on
the top reaching the top is much easier
than it is to stay there